hello
my name is xenia gassic i'm a peach
breeder and geneticist at clemson
university
i would like to thank the organizers for
giving me the opportunity to present
breeding data management in specialty
crops in this presentation i will
introduce you to breeding information
management system or bims demonstrate
its features and discuss some future
works so what is bims bims is an online
tool which allows users to explore the
publicly available reading data in the
host community databases while also
providing a data management solution for
private breeding programs currently bims
is available freely in the four
specialty club databases database for
rosate paxinium citrus and pulse
and also in the cotton database this
slide features all of these databases
the four databases that serve 26
specialty crops had a farm gate value in
2019 of 19.4 billion
they represent 52 percent of all u.s
specialty crops pims is supported by
nrsp 10 project and newly submitted
proposal to scri and in addition to the
database home pages the databases can be
accessed from
nrsp.org and
breedvidpims.org this slide lists
current functionalities of bims some of
which will be demonstrated later in this
presentation
detailed description of bims and all its
functionalities will be provided in the
manuscript that is currently in revision
in the database journal
this paper describes how breeders can
use bims to manage their private
breeding data and provides detailed
examples among the current
functionalities are to create the
programs add members and control
permission levels
manage upload and edit genotype and
phenotype data to create your own data
fields to store and search data manage
the field book app
perform statistical analysis perform
searches with various categories and
trade cutoff values
and archive the entire data at any time
so why bins in addition to described
functionalities there are more
advantages to use bims
since bims reside in the community
databases curated public breeding data
can be imported to your private program
the data includes phenotype and genotype
data
curated genomic data can also be used in
your private program for example you can
search for genotype data using genomic
positions of markers without importing
those data into your private program for
collaborative projects all or part of
data can be easily released to public
and projects and another advantage of
bims is that bims is built in triple
triple is a toolkit for database
construction used by over 100 databases
worldwide
in triple in addition to core modules
users worldwide can develop and share
extension modules
currently over 40 extension modules are
available bims is developed as an
extension module which means any triple
database can use bims future analysis
tools developed by users worldwide in
addition to work we are doing in an rsv
10 project can be implemented in
community databases to be used with bims
there are three main areas in the bims
interface
the header region displays the selected
cropped and program
and has links to the configuration page
account page and the home page of the
community database the second part of
the interface is the accordion menu on
the left side
this menu allows users to switch between
various sections of bills
the last region is the tab region and
this is where users primarily interact
with bims each tab in bims has an
instruction section that provides
information on how to use that tab
without logging in users can choose a
crop and a public beams program to view
data and explore bims the about beams
and help menus provide various
information including links to the bim's
manual and mailing list to import data
into bims the data needs to be in the
bims templates that are available for
download in the template list under the
data import section of the left hand
accordion menu phenotype data can also
be imported to bims using exported files
from fieldbook the data templates tab
lists all the templates with hyperlinks
to view and download the template
users can also download all the
templates as a single excel file once
the data has been entered into the
templates
users can load the data using the upload
data link
in the upload data tab the file name
will appear in the uploaded files
section after a file has been submitted
to view the progress of an upload job
users can click on the file name and
click the view button the manage reading
section lets users view create or edit
data for trait location cross accession
and trial in addition to program
when users click for example trait
the manage trade tab opens and shows all
the trade descriptors in the trade
section
when there is imported public phenotype
data the descriptor groups of both
public data and private data are
displayed
the admin menu allows changing the order
of the trades adding manually new trade
or merging the same descriptor
in different descriptor groups clicking
one trait opens straight details section
on the right that shows details of the
trade descriptor along with the
distribution of the trade values and
statistical summary of the full data set
loaded to bims at the bottom of the
trade details section delete and edit
buttons are available
the search section allows users to
search phenotype genotype and cross data
clicking on phenotype the search by
phenotype tab appears this tab has three
sections choose property set filter and
phenotype search results the first step
to start a search is to select a
property or trait under the choose
property section for example users can
choose trial under properties
after the property is selected the set
filters section will populate with
options for that data type after
selecting the options user can click the
add button the selected filter will then
appear in the phenotype search result
section users can further filter the
search results by adding another
property or trait under the choose
properties section users can further
refine the search by adding thresholds
for a trait the set filter section will
show the data that are relevant for the
previous chosen filter for example the
statistics shown for the fruit l meaning
fruit length trait is for the accessions
from the trials chosen in the previous
search users can set the minimum and
maximum value of this trait and then
click add which then adds the new filter
to the phenotype search result section
any selected filters can be removed with
the remove button under each filter
under the results section the
descriptions menu can be expanded to
show the filters that were used to
generate the initial table the data
analysis section of the accordion menu
lets users further analyze phenotype
data
here multiple data sets could be chosen
using categories and compare the trait
values among the multiple data sets
when users click statistical analysis
under data analysis the statistical
analysis tab appears
the tab has three sections categories
traits and statistics
users can select a category under
category section
in this example data year and then
choose multiple datasets in the second
box that pops up once a category is
selected categories include the
accession list which is the list of
accessions that users saved in the
search section
after choosing multiple data sets users
can click the compare button
when the computation is done users can
select a trait in the middle section in
this example
ssc or sugar content the statistics
section on the right will show a graph
with the distribution of the trait
values for each data set
a table below the graph will show the
statistical values for each data set
users can click the legend to deselect
some of the data set fields to view
subsets
the fieldbook management section of the
accordion menu provides functionality to
generate input files for fieldbook or
load data to bins using the fieldbook
output files two types of files the
field file and trade file can be
generated using data in bins to load to
the fieldbook app the configure
fieldbook section allows users to
pre-select columns that can be included
in the field file
by default the three columns required in
the field file unique identifier primary
order and secondary order as well as
accessions are downloaded in the field
file
the fieldbook configuration page allows
other columns to be included in the
fieldbook input file so that fieldbook
users can see those in the main screen
of the fieldbook app the trade link
under the generate input file section
opens a page where it lists all the
trades stored in the program
users can select all or part of the
trades to generate the trade file for
the fieldbook app the field link under
the generate input files section opens a
page with the three choices
new trial existing trial and cross the
new trial section lets users choose one
of the accession lists that are
generated and saved in the search
section
choose additional columns and generate
the field file existing trial section
can be used when users want to generate
a newly updated field file for the
existing trial
the cross section allows breeders to
automatically generate progeny names and
generate an input file for a new cross
readers can upload a file with the cross
name row and the number of progeny for
each row for bims to generate a
fieldbook input file with new progeny
names
customization is one of the very
important and unique features of bits in
addition to being able to add new traits
at any time bims offers various ways to
customize the data management the
customization can be done following the
links in various pages under the
accordion menu
users can access them through the
configuration page link on the top right
of each bim's page
the bim's fieldbook link in the
configuration page opens a tab where
users can change the column names
required for the fieldbook app input
file
users can also add custom columns in
templates to store their
various metadata unique to their
breeding program
those custom columns can be selected to
be used as search categories as well
through the search phenotype cross
genotype category links
the fieldbook link on the configuration
page lets users choose which traits
accession properties or sample
properties will be displayed in the
generate field book input file section
and resulting field book input file
finally the trait order link in the
configuration page lets users change the
order of trades displayed in the
manage breeding page
data and beams programs are backed up
nightly
on-site and off-site for security
the archives section of the accordion
menu however provides functionality for
readers to archive data at any time all
archived files can be accessed in the
user's account page
one of the newest functionalities in
bims
is that it is brapi compliant
which means you can import data in
fieldbook app to bims just by clicking
buttons some of the future developments
are provided here including management
of image data which is almost done
next one that we are working on is to
make brims accessible to breeders
without community databases to
breedwithbims.org
through the nrsp10 project that is
funded we are working on supporting
phenomx data
genome-wide association analysis
capability
global performance prediction capability
to allow allow performance prediction
based on genotype and environment
also to develop further analysis tools
and breeding decision tools and to
identify sustainability models
in the submitted scr project which is
spending we are proposing to further
develop fieldbook app
do more curation of public phenotype and
genotype data for the four community
databases and on-site training for bim's
field book app use
this is all i have we want to thank our
sponsors for providing funds and
supporting development of this important
breeding database
and i hope these presentations had
piqued your interest in beams and you
will check it out
i will be happy to answer any questions
thank you for your attention